we modify aircraft to include VIP
interiors to make it more like a home
environment than a commercial aircraft
environment we have seen an increased
emphasis on noise reduction in aircraft
sound level in a basic commercial
aircraft it only allow you to have good
speech interaction within one to two
feet of each other here we've gotten
down to about 47 decibels or they can
communicate eight to sixteen feet quite
easily once it was identified that you
could get lower then I was like whoa
let's see how far we can go
soundproofing is really a holistic
approach we apply a continuous
uninterrupted barrier of insulation we
also isolate the components that may
pass through that barrier to ensure
vibrations don't pass through and get
conducted into the interior and also we
have to treat the systems that are
within the barrier already such as air
conditioning fuel pumps ventilation fans
and whatnot it's really about
optimization the more sound attenuating
materials we add the more weight you
inherently add to the aircraft which
adversely affects the mission
requirements so there's quite a science
that goes into the development in these
systems this would be what would
typically come on an Airbus aircraft but
we developed a whole new system that for
only two-thirds the weight it's actually
10 decibels quieter or roughly half the
noise level the cost of a basic interior
well for a narrow-body aircraft that
would be a twenty five to thirty five
million dollar range whereas a wide-body
aircraft your 747 a380s those would be
on the order of ninety million dollars
more and that's just what we do from the
interior completion standpoint